well a battle is already underway on
Capitol Hill over how to handle Robert
Miller's findings the Attorney General
tells Congress his intent is to release
as much of the special counsels report
as the law allows that may be not enough
for the president's critics Paula Reid
is at the Justice Department Paul oh
good morning good morning the Attorney
General says he is mindful of the
enormous public interest in this case
and sources tell CBS News that over the
next few days he will be here with his
deputy rod Rosenstein members of the
office of legal counsel and some of
their other aides poring over this
report to figure out what else they can
release to the public but there are some
limits they cannot legally release grand
jury material and traditionally they
don't release information about people
who have not been charged but Democratic
leaders Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer
are demanding that the full report be
released but ultimately this is a win
for the president this is pretty much as
good as a not guilty verdict this
four-page letter and going forward it
will be interesting to see how much more
Democrats can get about whether or not
the president obstructed justice we have
to remember that six of the president's
advisors have been charged five of them
have been convicted and in addition to
investigations launched by House
Democrats federal prosecutors in New
York are looking into whether the
President may have committed any sort of
fraud in his business they're also
looking into his inaugural committee and
potential campaign finance violations
and all this is in addition to
investigations in DC and New York and a
possible tax fraud and questions about
whether or not the president may have
accepted foreign money through his
hotels so while the Russia investigation
is over the president's legal problems
continue Viana
that is clear Paula thank you